if you have sex you're going to get aids
and you're going to have a baby and like
have a baby and get aids and i'm going
to give you more weeds and then you have
to
take care of this baby you have an aids
baby at 17.
oh my god
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast's very first
episode
ah um i'm your host
elise morales former emo kids
scene kid theater kid of all the
various types of kid one could be
in uh early 2000's suburban virginia
on today's episode i am talking with
comedian bert kreischer and i'm going to
get right into the episode but
thank you so much for tuning in to this
our very first episode of the roast of
your teenage self podcast we have an
amazing
season with amazing interviews
coming at ya you're not you're not going
to want to
not be subscribed is what i'm going to
say and then the last thing that i'm
going to say and then i'm going to turn
it over
to the interview portion of the show is
that um for anyone
who's watching at home yes i did dye my
hair blonde immediately before doing
this recording
um what do you think do you think it
looks good my teenage self would never
it's crazy
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self
podcast i am your host your roast coming
queen
voted headed for hollywood in oakton
high school's 2008
graduating class elise morales
and with me today as our very first
guest we have comedian actor
author host former teenager
graduate of tampa jesuit high school
you have no idea i've been thinking
about my teenage self so much because
i've been in quarantine with my 15 year
old and my 13 year old
does like a lot of your do memories come
back like watching them go through being
teenagers
i am obsessed right now not obsessed
that sounds really creepy i sound like
ti
but i'm obsessed with i'm obsessed with
uh
my daughter george's first kiss like she
hasn't had it yet and when she does have
it
we will be coming out of social
distancing and i think to myself
what an interesting first kiss it will
be to have a boy
break the six foot barrier and her being
like what are you doing
like it's just you know a first kiss
after social distancing
i remember my first kiss and the girl
did it she she led into it
oh if i could get i think i look for
that feeling every time i drink that
feeling of your stomach
dropping how old how old were you when
you got your first kiss
seventh grade same i was in seventh
grade
and it was at the end we went to see the
third harry potter movie in theaters and
i'm a huge
harry potter person and so i would not
let him kiss me for the entire movie
because i was like focused on
the movie so we kissed immediately
after the movie ended can i tell you
that you're the type of person that i
love in life
is someone who knows what they like and
knows what they want and is focused
see i'm someone that would give up on
anything precious
to get those life experiences like if if
i if say i loved uh the los
angeles rams when we were at a game and
my wife's like it's it's monday night
football they're playing the chiefs it's
down to the last play and my wife's like
hey you want a hand job and a toilet
stall and i'd be like okay let's go
right now and i'd give up on everything
practice
see i think i think for me i knew even
even at my young age i was like
he'll wait and we'll kiss at the end
this boy is 13 he wants to kiss me it's
gonna happen
we'll wait until i see how they kind of
reenact my one of my favorite books
on screen all right so i'm gonna ask
like
a couple quick questions just to get
like a picture
of your teenage self so much has been
made of your
like college partying life yeah
but was that part of your life
in high school or were you like i want
to be dedicated to my catholic education
in my sports
it was not me i did not party at all i
was terrified of marijuana i'd i'd
smoked it a couple times
and it freaked me out i didn't like
drinking i was terrified
of getting hung over so i would fake
drink like i'd have a sip and then
put it off to the side and be like oh
i'm wasted i
was not me at all i was i was kind of
focused on baseball
but i was i was always funny
but i was i was i was a lot a lot more
serious and
a lot like 100 percent more serious in
high school about life
about being hippie about music about
growing my hair out but i was terrified
of marijuana and i was
i was really scared of getting wasted
drunk wow so
what flipped that switch did that happen
at the end of high school or was that
fully in college i didn't drink i didn't
drink my freshman year really like i
said i got drunk a couple times
but not like not like i got wasted once
my freshman year and maybe i'd have a
couple beers but i didn't really care
for it
i didn't i barely drank it all my
sophomore year um and my junior year
my junior a few things happened my my
actually was my first sophomore my
second sophomore year
is um my parents split up
i got in a band i i
i turned 21
and i and i i enjoyed beer for the first
time i remember
uh michelob lights were like my beer
like it was a beer i enjoyed
and and i started to make more friends
but still i never really
partied it wasn't until i went to russia
that i legit i swear to god where i was
like i know that's such a good beginning
to a story
it wasn't until i went to russia yeah
and that and in russia
i didn't speak the language but i knew
that if we drank all drank together we'd
laugh together
and then coming home i started leaning
into it really hard i was like
oh i like partying like partying's a fun
and i got cheated on
by my girlfriend at the time who slept
with my best friend and that was a great
way to tap it out my god my buddy mike
osborne was like
hey man i know this isn't great advice
but i know if you drink those feelings
go away and i was like
okay so that's so interesting to me
because
i kind of had a similar track myself
where like in high school i was just
too scared of getting in trouble to like
really push the envelope or like smoke
weed
or drink or anything because i just like
i was i remember i went high to
play practice one time to wizard of oz
rehearsal
and i was i like i was sweating i was so
terrified the entire time that
the drama teacher was going to know that
i had like smoked a joint or whatever
that it was like the worst experience of
my life
yeah i was terrified of drinking and
driving i'm this is going to sound like
not people won't understand this
coming from a guy who robbed a train in
russia but
i'm a big rule follower like i'm a big
rule follower
and so i've always been and so i didn't
want to drink underage
because i didn't want to get arrested
because i didn't want my dad to be like
what the [ __ ] and i didn't want to do
drugs because i didn't want to have
drugs on me
because i didn't want to get arrested
with drugs and then go to jail and so
like
i was a really crazy rule follower and
still am in a weird way i really am a
a pretty intense rule follower but my
wife will always say that i only apply
the rules when i only listen to rules
when
and i don't think they don't they apply
to me like i always break rules when
like
like i bring little bottles of booze on
planes and pour in my like
so i'm a mess but that's why i didn't
party
the big rules maybe yeah i don't cheat
on my wife
but i always cheated on chicks all
growing up like you know like i was
i was just i was a bad i i'm i'm i'm i'm
i said it on my i have a podcast with
tom's girl called tubers one cave
i said it last week i'm a legit
hypocrite yeah i feel like
my when i was going to high school i was
getting the like
anti-hazing craze like it was like
the year was 2005 and we had realized
it's not cool to let
students torture each other i was
watching uh
days and confused with my kids and they
were paddling
you know one of the kids they catch him
and they paddle him and my daughters
were appalled they're like why are they
torturing him i said no no that's hazing
and they're like what i said that's
hazing that happened to me too and
they're like you had
older boys beat you with a stick and i
was like
yeah and then i did it to younger boys
like that was the deal it's like that's
how you became a man is
you were tortured then you tortured
people right like there was a legit
week in high school called hell week we
had to wear bean
we had to wear beanies like little
beanies with a j and a little
visor you can find it online type in
tampa jesuit beanie
and we used to wear little beanies our
freshman year for the whole first
two semesters you had to wear a beanie
and the key was you take the little knot
like this little part of it
you take that out because the seniors
would come up and go
smack and pop it in your head so you
took that out and then there
there was a full week where if you were
caught on campus
they would haze you and the teachers
would be like get over there get over
there
elephant walk come on let's go i mean it
was legit
and then when i went to college there
was like aggressive hazing
to kind of hazing where you go i'm not
doing that to anybody like it was
horrific but yeah that was childhood
i have a couple photos of you from high
school and i have one
photo in front of me here where you're
sitting on sort of a white leather
couch you have like a trippy shirt on
which i think if i zoom in on
looks like it has the cat in the hat
maybe smoking weed on it or it
looks like it yeah i know i remember
that stage in my life
that is like that is like 1819
and that is that is
when i went to college when i left i
left for college when i was 17 i think
and i i remember my dad saying buddy you
don't have to be who you were
in high school like you're gonna make
new friends if there's a part of you you
don't like
change it now and i remember i didn't
like that i was a little bit of a meat
head like i was i've always been a bit a
bit of a bro
but like i was a big time meathead in
high school like
like sports and chicks and like that's
it
it was like that's it really fist fights
on weekends
like i was and i'm not saying i was a
tough guy but i just was
a my friends were mouth breathers i was
a mouth breather
we liked the taste of windows we licked
windows like that's where we were
and you're also at an all boys school so
your life is just being with other high
school boys
oh yeah reinforcing high school boy
behavior a punch in the dick
it made us laugh hysterically like very
low brow sense of humor and and
you know and a lot of it revolved around
genitals and
and farts and so when i went to college
i was like i remember getting there and
going to the student union and finding
the grateful dead and being like what's
a grateful dead and having heard of them
but not knowing
what they did and listening to them and
being like oh [ __ ] i found fish and
widespread panic
and i was like you know i've never read
a book i just never read a book i've
never
read a [ __ ] book and so i'm almost
certain i can tell you that that book
i'm reading right there
is um the firm by uh
by uh what's his name john grisham
that came out my freshman year and it
was like all anyone talked about and i
remember going like
i'm gonna read a book
[Laughter]
because i wanted to be a different
person yeah when they're like i'm
actually just gonna
i'm gonna read a book yeah and i and so
it was like grow a goatee i had short
hair because i was pledging a fraternity
so it was like it was like a it was like
i was going to be a brand new me little
did i know i was joining a fraternity
full of meat heads
that are still my friends to this day
and we're not going to let me grow into
whatever the [ __ ] i thought i was
growing
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast
is brought to you by purple technology
has improved
just about everything phones cars
shopping
yet mattresses have been more or less
the same since
the invention of sleep but we deserve
better
don't we friends and finally the
mattress has
evolved thanks to purple the secret to
purple
is the purple grid it's a patented
comfort technology that instantly adapts
to your body's
natural shape and sleep style purple is
for everybody
no matter how you sleep and purple is
designed with over 2 800
open air channels and naturally
temperature neutral
gel so you'll never sleep too hot
or too cold is it tmi for me to tell you
guys that
i sleep kind of too hot did i get kind
of
sweaty in my sleep i feel like i've
shared enough with you
on this podcast and will continue to do
so that i can i can let you know i'm a
hot sleeper but
not with purple okay the purple mattress
is
soft where you want it firm where you
need it and comfortably
cool all over thank goodness
now i don't have to wake up in a puddle
of sweat
it's truly a mattress that does it oh
you know
here's the thing guys i recently moved
and i recently upgraded my lifestyle
and part of upgrading my lifestyle was
upgrading
my pillows okay i was working with again
just nasty pillows okay some of them
flip floppity not nose
no firmness some of them way too stuffed
up my neck is hurting because of how
fluffed up the pillow is
but not anymore i'm sleeping
easy with the purple pillow and you can
count on
resting easy night after night year
after year because the ultra
durable purple grid won't sink or lose
shape
purple is so confident in what they do
that every purple mattress comes with
free shipping
and returns and a risk-free hundred
night trial 100 nights can you even
imagine
where you'll be 100 nights from now so
experience
the next evolution of sleep go to
purple.com teen
self and use the promo code teen self
all of those words are spelled the way
that they're normally spelled
for a limited time and you will get 150
dollars off any purple mattress order of
hundred 1500 or more so that's
purple.com
team self promo code teen self for a
hundred and fifty dollars off
any mattress order of fifteen hundred
dollars or more
terms apply
so okay so this picture is like you're
now you're in college you're
like 18 19 you found the grateful dead
etc
but i also have a prom picture of you
so i imagine that's a couple years
earlier
that that is a that is probably not even
a prom photo
that is probably sophomore year of high
school
it's with uh amy buckman god rest her
soul
oh she lost her way passed away passed
away doing the right thing that's what's
frustrating about life she
was in i think going to school
university of miami and they were
they were out partying and she got in a
cab and the cab got hit by a drunk
driver
oh my god it breaks my heart my dad's
really good friends with her mom and dad
uh bucky and cookie that picture defines
to me
i had this time in my life where i just
thought
everything should be bigger or better
does that make sense
like i i i like i just thought there's
got to be people doing this bigger than
me
like me and my friends we were all close
we had a great time and we laughed
hysterically
but there was a weird part of me that
was like that i didn't get i don't i
don't think
i just think i recently got rid of that
feeling but
that things were happening cooler or
faster or better
or bigger for other people and that how
did i get in those circles
how did i get and i look at that picture
and i remember
going like now i look at that picture
and i go like amy was younger than me
and and uh a year younger than me and i
felt like i felt like uh
i i you know i felt like uh like an
older like my buddy we chose in the same
grade as her
and and i remember going there and being
like
i shouldn't be with a girl younger than
me i should be with a girl older than me
now i look back and i'm like she's
[ __ ] beautiful why like
she's beautiful she is beautiful in that
video but it's so funny the like the
things that matter to you
when you're in high school like the
difference between a sophomore and a
freshman is like
well she's a freshman and now you're
like who the hell
cares she's a babe like that was her
dance that was her i think
coleman high school dance and i and she
was in ninth grade
were you a big flirt like what was your
like okay let's say like
teenage bird likes a girl what's he
doing
teenage bird is very different than
grown up bird that's a very teenage bert
was
very comfortable uh trying to kiss
someone very comfortable
uh probably not reading
uh cues a girl gave out like like i just
was like
like i mean i just remember like being
very
comfortable with myself and for whatever
reason
college bert lost it like just so
interesting well i think i think i was i
think i was
a bull in a china shop in high school
like like just like i remember like
just i had a i wanted to get laid i
wanted to get laid so bad when i was a
freshman
that was like my thing uh i dated a
young lady
i dated a girl my grade that i didn't
want to have sex and we just broke up
because she didn't have sex and i did
like that was a reason to break up with
someone
like oh yeah and but i remember thinking
that's so important to get laid and then
i had
sex for the first time when i was 17 and
i [ __ ] it up
so bad and i realized uh
this guy is not real uh the guy i'm
driving to be
is not really who i am and has no
connection to who i am as a
as a as a boy i'm a boy i remember
thinking i'm not ready to
have a baby get aids all the things that
happened with having sex right because
at that time like
that was i imagine the messaging you
were getting is like
if you have sex you're going to get aids
and you're going to have a baby and like
have a baby and get aids
and i'm going to baby and then you have
to take care of this baby you have an
aids baby at 17. oh my god
i remember they showed us a video when i
was in
high school which should have been like
the early 2000s
that was made in like the 80s and it was
it was like i just remember this really
bizarre 80s graphic that said like 10
000 babies a year are born addicted to
crack
and like just like this crazy video that
they showed us
and i was and i i was like this is not
something that suburban teenagers from
like virginia
are dealing with at all i'll beat you
i'll beat you
in spades on that one 10th grade
uh mr merkin dante brought in a video
into religion
hit play and we watched a third
trimester
full abortion like
for those of you that don't know and i i
apologize if this is crass
that is the baby is completely formed
and they go
into the woman and break it apart piece
by piece and then remove it from her
it was aggressive
i mean i i'm i was like well why did
they do that and i'm like i know why
they did that
to make you not like abortion but yeah
what so i'm like so shocked that's
because i went to public school so we
were
not it's pretty aggressive right it's
pretty aggressive
yeah this is back when you could hit
kids this is like a different life a
little bit
and it and for some of us it was like i
would never to this day
i'm obviously i have two kids but i
would i never thought about abortion
abortion wasn't an option i would never
get an abortion
and then my roommate in new york who i
grew up with and went to same school
with and sat next to me in that class
he had like six abortions with six
different girls and he was like i guess
i saw a different
perspective he's like you know you saw a
glass half empty i saw glass half full i
went
so there's options i was like how
religious did you
personally feel during that time like
were you watching that video and you
were like
yeah well like you were just said you
were like yeah abortion's bad or like
or are you like are you really into
being religious at that point or what's
your relationship to that
i was very religious at that point like
i was
but you know it was also at a time when
when i didn't like i remember not
knowing i remember not like
if you didn't believe in god that just
meant you were going to hell so i didn't
know why
anyone would ever do that and so and
i was skeptical i remember being in
religion class skeptical
as almost like a true comedian would be
just a contrarian to whatever the
teacher
said but 17 years old lost my virginity
and for two months every sunday went to
church
every sunday went to church and prayed
st mary's right down the street from my
house i went to church by myself
as a 17 year old i wonder what people
must have thought see a 17 year old in
there they're like
oh either he's getting molested or he
got someone pregnant yeah like something
something serious is going on with that
yeah and i still i still
i still have my jesus piece like i'm i'm
like
i have a connection i just thought
recently i was thinking about when i
had that period when i was going to
church by myself um
and i thought you know i wouldn't i i
i can understand finding religion in a
time like this when
when things are a little uncertain i
understand people who
want to go i would i was part of me was
like i would love
going to church right now just yeah
tapping out and going sunday and
putting on something nice some khakis
and nice shoes and
a collared shirt and sitting down and
listening like
i wouldn't mind it i actually looked
sunday on easter sunday
i looked for uh masses on tv
and the only one i could find was the
pope in italian and then obviously we're
in la
a lot of them in spanish yeah
uh i saw a bunch of people were like do
trying to find
mass on tv and stuff but it's like i
mean that's why i'm
there's so much that's missing in the
way that we currently have to do things
but like
that feeling of actually entering a
church and like the sanctity of a church
is like
you can't really oh yeah being in a
church the smell of the church the feel
of the
of the there's so much the
uncomfortableness of a pew
getting on your knees there's so much
the taste of communion on the roof of
your mouth
there's so much about church the the
being in in
in in uniform with everyone else when
they're like when everyone stands
together and everyone sits together
it's so funny you don't even realize you
do it i haven't been to church forever
but it's so interesting that you have
this like
you're like good catholic boy who
is like playing his sports and like
going to church alone
and then flip that maybe fast forward
like
five years and your number one partier
at the number one party school in
america
like what do you think is at the heart
of that
transformation i think there's a lot
of not knowing who the [ __ ] i was i mean
i mean i didn't know who i was until i
was probably
42 is when i figured out who i was like
i mean
i got glimpses of who i was but and i
still i mean i'm still kind of lost i
don't know
when i mean i get lost at times i'm less
lost now
but there's times i look at my kids and
i go yeah i have no idea what i'm doing
like i can't believe you're
hanging your hat on me at the end of the
day
so i i don't know i think i think i was
just genuinely
i was always trying to figure out who i
was i mean you have if you could go back
there are huge periods like long hair
short hair hair dyed white um hair dyed
pink uh uh playing the guitar in a band
uh playing sports
um you know like uh running what was the
name of your band
giving out spankings awesome
wait you've never heard my band story
it's a good one
i did not so i was in college when i was
turning when i turned 21 i was in a band
with john daker brent bracken and ben
carter and we
brought in another guitarist from our
fraternity a transfer student
we brought him into play and he played
with us for a few times like
maybe 10 15 times but we had a good band
and one day
we i realized very quickly this guy was
too good that he was so good that he was
going to realize i couldn't sing and ben
bren brent bracken couldn't play bass
and kick us out
and i wasn't about to lose my band and
it was brent bracken's garage we were
playing in so we kicked him out
he was like i'm like the best guy in the
band and we're like well yeah now you're
the best guy not in the band
so he started a band
uh called creed wow yeah so creed
is uh can i take you
everyone can thank me for that so crazy
so you know you started a band called
creed if you just let this guy be in
your band he would now i
look he he laughs it off and he says
none of that's true i don't know what
he's talking about
like mark truman he's a cool guy i get
it we all have different narratives in
our life
but i will tell you right now
i definitely take credit for cree
hell yeah all right i think
that it is time for us to wrap it up so
i'm gonna end uh with just i feel like a
classic
question but bert if you had one thing
to tell your teenage self
what would you tell them by the way i
don't want to say something that my fans
would say to me like
hey stop talking and listen
[Laughter]
i would say to my teenage self
uh slow down
like slow down it's okay it's gonna
happen
you don't need to be in a rush slow down
people are gonna like you for exactly
who you are
just wait like i just wanted to be so
many different people
yeah and i wanted i wanted to be the
person that
i wanted to be the person that i thought
people liked so much in my life and then
it wasn't until i was
me and it wasn't until i was me like a
much later version of me i was just
telling this to guy fiatti today
on the on a skype i was saying i was
sitting in an
upfront's first travel channel and he
was on stage and i thought
i'm on the wrong path this is like six
years ago i go i'm on the wrong path
what am i doing in an auditorium
listening to him speak i want to be the
one on the stage i want to be the one
i know that's an egotistical thing to
say about i want to be the one where
people come to a theater to see me speak
like that's what i want
and i i i think it take i think
sometimes it takes
losing everything and not knowing who
you are for real and being like so what
the [ __ ] do i do now to get there
so i do i would tell that the high
school kid with a full head of hair i
would tell him two things i'd say get
some pictures of yourself
naked now do not get rid of those you're
going to want to see those later
trust me it's the same dick with a much
bigger body you're going to want to look
back at the same deck with a much
smaller body
get a lot of naked pictures uh don't
wear condoms and slow down
okay get nudes don't wear condoms you're
not getting aids buddy it's okay
you're fine it's not gonna happen and
actually in a couple years they'll
actually have really really good
treatments and you'll be able to be able
to live a full
natural life even if you did get aids
anyway
but it's been wonderful to have you as
our very first guest on the podcast
thank you so much for your time thank
you so much for
all the stories uh and until next time
this has been the roast of your teenage
[Music]
self